salut je m'appelle fabien olicard et
dans ce nouveau concept on va parler du
cerveau avec à chaque fois un regard
spécifique sur un point particulier
aujourd'hui on va voir à quel point
c'est un gros mytho alors nouveaux
décors nouveaux formats bienvenue dans
matière grise
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ce premier épisode nous allons
vivre cinq expériences expérience une la
démonstration expérience 2 le test
expérience 3 d'expériences scientifiques
avec une trentaine de personnes
expérience 4 c'est à vous expérience 5
l'expérience comportementale avec de
nouveau une trentaine de personnes
notre cerveau traite des informations en
permanence et quand il n'a pas la
réponse à nos questions by les inventer
nous on est bien obligé de le croire
c'est le cas par exemple de notre vision
à l'arrière de l'oeil se trouve un point
qu'on appelle le point aveugle c'est
l'endroit précis où se connecte le nerf
optique et les vaisseaux sanguins
il n'y a pas de photorécepteurs à cet
endroit ça veut dire donc en permanence
dans notre champ de vision se trouvent
deux points noirs non les voit pas parce
que le cerveau décide de remplacer ces
points noirs par n'importe quelle image
et nous on est bien obligé de le croire
c'est d'ailleurs exactement la même
chose pour notre mémoire nous conclusion
notre raisonnement nos sensations ce
sont des feuilles cognitive et même plus
que les magiciens savent exploiter
depuis toujours les magiciens et les
neuroscientifiques ont été passionnés
par le cerveau mais en faisant leurs
travaux en parallèle du moins jusqu'en
2007 où a eu lieu à las vegas le 1er
congrès qui a réuni ces deux groupes
pour un symposium et ouvrir un dialogue
pourquoi la magie fonctionne j'ai invité
benjamin verrecchia pour en savoir un
petit peu plus et on va commencer par un
tour de carte bancaire un papy ils
essaient de me tuer
je n'ai eu mentalement celle ci voit là
bas et je prends celle là voilà j'ai pas
attention ceci te convient et celle là
me convient je la montre c'est bon tu
l'armée comme là tu me dis décalé romy
si tu me dis elle est totalement remise
mais c'est fou je n'ai pas senti et tu
sais quoi ça c'est envoie un message
inconscient de je ne sais pas du tout
que tu la remise je ne sais pas où aller
du coup je mélange un petit peu quand ce
train là même où il faudrait un
téléphone très rapide pour la suite de
ce numéro est ce que tu connais le one
plus cet epr aux éditions mclaren j'en
ai entendu parler je n'ai jamais vu il
est là aujourd'hui je te laisse regarder
sur ta gauche discrètement le roi +7 tpr
au de chez mclaren 1 vraiment christine
her l'arrêt non plus
en fait il ne lui manque que les roues
il a une connexion bluetooth est
incroyable en l'approchant du jeu de
cartes
on peut faire comme sa rentrée l'âme
d'une carte à l'intérieur du téléphone
différents thèmes la chanteuse oui tu
peux tu veux mais alors il faut vraiment
appuyé on embrasse l'âme t'as vu la
carte à bouger ça veut dire qu'elle est
prête à sortir je peux la sortir et
essayer de vérifier si c'est ta carte ou
pas ta carte évidemment on a eu quelques
arrêtés
c'était le 8 de carreaux le 8 de
carreaux qui est aussi le 8 de carottes
de benjamin bravo benjamin l'effort
là tu vois jouer à ce petit soupçon de
5.3 rbds en uniforme
notre cerveau prend environ 35000
décisions par jour et pourtant on a
interrogé des personnes qui pensaient
elles prendre 92 décisions par jour en
moyenne pourquoi parce qu'à chaque
seconde
nos cinq sens et les autres sens comme
la terre mot ception la prius et psion
reçoivent des centaines et des centaines
d'informations traitées majoritairement
par l'inconscient le conscient lui n'en
traite à peu près qu'une dizaine un jour
une expérience a été menée par jay
sanguinetti il a publiée dans
psychological magazines ont leur montrer
les images que vous allez voir dans
quelques secondes et tout en faisant ça
on mesurer leur activité cérébrale
ces images sont abstraites mais les
formes blanches ressemblent à deux
chevaux blancs sur cet électron à ces
programmes
on constate que le cerveau a reconnu des
chevaux mais a décidé de ne pas envoyer
cette information au conscient
la psychologue marie peterson précise ce
pic cérébrale indiquent qu'ils ont
traité la signification de ses formes
mais le cerveau les rejette en tant qu
interprétation et s'ils rejettent les
formes de la perception consciente
alors on ne peut pas en avoir
connaissance alors que s'est-il passé
lors du tour de magie est-ce que tu as
une solution potentielle à me donner
[Musique]
en fait quand a sorti la carte
ma première réaction c'était il ya une
carte en dessous ça coûte quoi que non
quand j'ai pris le téléphone je sentais
pas de carte
ce taux qui me l'a donné à ben oui donc
y avait pas de carton sur le téléphone
on va y revenir dans quelques secondes
après rien parce que vraiment rien de
adacore suivent entre le lauquet ya rien
du tout en fait ta fraise est excellente
c'est ben oui c'est en fait le principe
des tours de magie
associé au biais cognitifs aux
raccourcis du cerveau etc
ils sont magnifiques parce que la
première idée qui t'est venue c'est
forcément la bonne à savoir
ouais mais le premier truc qui m'est
venue c'est de me dire il y avait une
carte en dessous évidemment il y avait
une carte en dessous voici ce qui s'est
passé mettons une carte n'importe
laquelle dix ans le 10 de coeur moi j'ai
juste fait en sorte sans rentrer dans
les détails que le 10 de coeur se
retrouvent plié sous le jeu doit plier
en quatre comme ceux-ci d'accord mais
comment tu arrive aussi vite a publié
une carte même sachez noël moi j'ai pas
bien compris est un service ou un plat
je crois et après tu m'a passé le
téléphone donc là je vais le prendre
les pasdaran dessous pour amener la
carte en dessous sous prétexte de
connectivité enfin la fameuse blague sur
le bluetooth y assure détournement
d'attention ou du moins psychologique
ensuite on appuie et ensuite j'ai fait
ce geste hyper technique qui était de
glisser la carte sous le téléphone mais
comme c'est la bonne réponse mais que tu
as eu des failles tout le long de ta
mémoire en fait sur ce qui s'est passé
exactement dans le bon sens en dessous
de blagounettes refuse l'idée et c'est
ce dont on parlera plus tard dans nos
prochaines expériences à savoir que
quand le cerveau après une décision ou a
fait une conclusion il a beaucoup de mal
à changer d'avis il préfère rejeter le
truc bien sûr il a en gagnant le seul
vrai bien sûr alors que toi tu avais
sommes heureusement parce que sinon on
pourrait plus faire de magie et ce
serait moins un monde sans logis siens
non hors de question en hors de question
je préfère encore me faire avoir des
milliers d'années c'est beau ce que tu
dit mais bien sûr j'aime les magiciens
s'étouffe aux tricots repos parce que
j'ai un bon vous l'avez compris ça va
c'est clair c'est l'instant promo de la
vidéo qui permet de financer ce nouveau
format d'ailleurs y'a pas de publicité
dans la vidéo parce que j'ai un
partenaire
vous avez également compris que notre
cerveau est un super calculateur un jour
il ya pas si longtemps on a essayé de
reproduire une seconde activité
cérébrale de notre cerveau il a fallu
aux meilleurs ordinateurs du monde 40
minutes pour reproduire cette seconde de
calcul
donc c'est juste énorme mais vous avez
aussi vu il ya quelques secondes que
pour que notre cerveau soit très
efficace
il est obligé d'être imprécis un parfait
de nous mentir en permanence et je
connais un super calculateur qui lui ne
fait pas de compromis entre la rapidité
et l'efficacité c'est le wall +7 tpr aux
éditions mclaren alors déjà pour vous
prévenir la dernière fois qu'ils ont
fait une édition spéciale avec mclaren
c'est parti en deux 2 vous avez un lire
dans la description
il embarque toute la technologie
évidemment du set tu es pro mais il a
des trucs un peu par exemple il a 12
giga de ram c'est plus performant que
certains ordi la rapidité c'est une des
synergies qu'ils ont avec mclaren mais
une autre c'est quand même le design de
deux dingues qui a dessus comme vous
êtes en train de voir il est vraiment
aux couleurs de mclaren avec un petit
liseré orange papaye un effet tpt fibre
de carbone au dos c'est pas si facile à
dire c'est en référence aux matériaux
utilisés dans la nouvelle voiture de
chez mclaren
c'est vraiment un produit qui est super
beau ils ont fait attention au moindre
détail et même sur les coques silos et
que tu peux me voilà la coque merci loïc
c'est une cote spécialement conçu pour
ce smartphone
allez faites en alcantara c'est le
matériau qui est située sur les volants
des voitures on est sur une très belle
synergie entre les deux marques
regardez le lien dans la description
pour en savoir plus ou pouvoir des
photos hyper cool et toutes les spé
merci one plus
c'est un mélange de détournement
d'attention et de ces cités au
changement la cécité au changement c'est
lorsqu'on lourd cligne des yeux on
n'arrive pas à refaire exactement la
même image et de pouvoir la comparer la
évident on cligne pas des yeux mais
c'est comme si à cause des changements
de valeur de plans ça fonctionne pareil
les détournement d'attention c'est parce
qu'on envoie au cerveau le message qu'il
faut focaliser sur une tâche négliger
toutes les autres informations
en l'occurrence on y demande de
focaliser sur les gobelets en fait les
seules fois benjamin ou le cerveau remet
en cause son propre jugement c'est quand
la majorité des personnes autour de nous
disent ou font ou pense quelque chose
d'autre
ou quand on boit de l'alcool également
alors oui et si la majorité hutu mais la
raison en particulier par contre avec
les chiffres là les chiffres c'est
quelque chose de très compliqué à
appréhender
parce que ça représente rien
visuellement parlant en fait mais on
peut faire une expérience nous vraiment
le résultat est très étonnant il va
peut-être te faire qui vais sur un grand
nombre de personnes par exemple tous les
abonnés qui sont venus ici
merci beaucoup bonjour on peut faire une
expérience ensemble avec un résultat
collectif pour voir un peu leur jugement
vis-à-vis des chiffres c'est une
expérience qui a été fait plusieurs fois
dont la dernière fois dans la série
brain games saison 5 épisode 1 que je
t'invite à regarder un jour mais ces
deux mêmes choses qu'on va faire
d'accord mais je vais je préfère la
tertiaire on va reproduire une
expérience qui me fascine
particulièrement et c'est une expérience
pour laquelle vous devez être nombreux
et c'est le cas aujourd'hui c'est cool
c'est maintenant par tout le secteur en
déclin les acteurs thé et des fois tu
sais tu dis tiens on prend qui en
invités et a plein qui sont pas dispo et
appelle les pierres qui est trop
distendu oui c'est une expérience
d'estimation je vous demandais d'estimé
quelque chose je vais vous poser une
question et on va tous vous interrogez
j'ai besoin des résultats de tout le
monde
ne vous laissez pas influencer par les
réponses des autres là je vous mets en
garde ce coup ci vous pouvez dès que
j'ai posé la question réfléchir à votre
estimation personnelle
il n'y a pas de bonne ou mauvaise
réponse y aura de très grands écarts et
c'est pas grave du tout ok
soyez libre de vos pensées soyez
vous abonner à cette chaîne abonnez vous
la question du jour
et quel est d'après vous en maïs non en
kilomètres km j'ai vu vraiment des yeux
t'ai vu sur la distance en kilomètres
d'un paris new york
tout le monde sait où et paris mais
certaines des questions intéressantes
et puis alors quel arrondissement va on
précise pas quoi on va dire qu'on fait
première couronne première couronne à
l'intra muros
on va on va prendre toutes vos réponses
et moi qui vais les éclairs ça ira plus
vite ou où tu veux faire le script de
benjamin alors là c'est un vidéo c'est
le jeu sera honoré qui fait de script ne
serait ce que pour sentir 5
quelle est ta réponse 9000 kilomètres
s'il te plaît ok ta réponse cinquante
mille hockey
4500 9500 je dirais je dirais 9000 sa
baisse est en estimation benjamin verica
le problème si je la connais elle le
club exactement de quatre mois j'ai
enfin en vrai j'ai fait un détour par le
texas un bond des tours après que
j'allais je dirais je dirai au bas mot 1
six mille 6000 km ok tu es un peu au
dessus mais c'est pas mal
6000 km j'ai déjà spoil apple qui est
intéressant c'est pas les bonnes et les
mauvaises réponses
en fait la distance précise et 2 5681
kilomètres je crois à vol d'oiseau
d'accord ok et là on a des écarts qui
vont apparemment ont fait plusieurs fois
le tour de la planète après new york a
des trucs deux apparemment c'est à côté
de chez moi 2000 km si vraiment tu
prends un avion qui te disent et 2000 km
tu finis vraiment dans l'océan attention
à l'atterrissage mais il ya quelque
chose qui qui qui est en fait la somme
de la moyenne des jugements et qui
s'approche toujours de la vérité
maintenant on va voir si on enlève juste
les gros extrêmes donc les quatre plus
gros extrême 100000 65 me pourquoi j'en
rêve que des groupes et à la fonction en
fait là pour moi les extrêmes c'est ce
qu'ils vont vraiment très très très très
loin et donc dans les petits on n'a pas
de trop loin en ald 2000 mais il est
passif par rapport aux hommes donc si on
se dit il ya une vraie erreur du
jugement de leur part et qu'on refait le
calcul
benjamin bien sûr donc du coup son stylo
d'ailleurs maintenant après la virgule
6000 24,5 km sachant que la distance et
de 5681 on est encore plus précis en
faisant ça bravo à vous et à votre
journal
c'est incroyable pour moi c'est fort en
fait un groupe
ouais plus les groupes et gros en plus
cette voie de créer une bonne réponse
par sa propre moyen exactement en fait
là la moyenne des jugements d'un groupe
avec les contributions individuelles de
chacun des membres donnera toujours un
résultat qui tend vers la vérité tout le
groupe est gros plus on aura un résultat
proche de la vérité parce que les
extrêmes au fur et à mesure vont
s'annuler dire que si vous étiez un
groupe de 100 il ya même pas besoin
d'enlever des extrêmes c'est une
certitude puisque les extrêmes danse
annulée au bout d'un moment ça
je demande aux gens combien de plat de
pâtes je me fais par mois si on a toutes
les réponses et que je donne la vraie
réponse
elle pourrait se rapprocher extrêmement
intéressant je reprends la main sur
crayon parce que non la france est donc
pourquoi parce qu'il ya quand même une
donnée à prendre en compte c'est qu'on
parle d'estimation donc il nous faut des
valeurs des points de départ des repères
là ce serait un élément du je pense que
quoi en fait tu as quoi mais je peux pas
leur dire combien il ya de feuille sur
un arbre dehors s'ils n'ont pas vu de
l'arbre parce qu'il faut un vrai point
de référence au caire là j'avais juste
mis la carte pour redonner un petit peu
des proportions je vous dis ok si
quelqu'un se souvient que par exemple la
rochelle-paris ses 500 kilomètres
peut-être que celle l'aide à se faire
une valeur cette expérience est issu de
la typologie des tâches de steinert paru
en 1972 qui dit je cite dans une tâche
compensatoires la moyenne des jugements
correspond à la contribution
individuelle de chaque membre en clair
la moyenne des jugements correspond
approximativement à la valeur exacte
[Musique]
dans cette expérience vous vous posez
des questions avoué aussi à benjamin n'y
a rien de difficile
l'idée c'est de répondre le plus vite
possible il n'y a pas de piège si ce
n'est les pièges de ton cerveau et de
leur cerveau ok d'accord je leur pose la
question à eux et après tu donnes ta
réponse
d'accord je suis cobayes en réaction
exactement et surtout la première
réponse qui te viendrait à l'esprit
parce qu'en temps normal je te
demanderai une réponse directe
instantané c'est ce qu'ils vont faire
que chez eux ils mentir on dans les
commentaires mais d'abord au caire n'est
pas ok et donc moi je dis ce qui me
passe par l'esprit
bah ouais mais que quand je te le
demande donc tu as ta réponse élevé plus
la même et que d'ailleurs metula modifie
pas après en ayant
on réfléchit comme un jeu de cartes
exactement je choisis ma carte je bouge
pas exactement très bien le deux pics de
toutes races et j'étais pas venu à bout
profitez pas si mal question numéro une
caisse qui est le plus lourd parmi ceux
qui apparaît à l'écran à savoir un kilo
de plans ou un kilo de plumes
on veut savoir ce qui est le plus lourd
le plus dense réfléchissez 3 2 à berne
avec à votre réponse ma réponse que
c'est le même poids puisque c'est un
kilo exactement c'est le même poids
c'est un kilo c'est exactement la bonne
réponse mais certains d'entre vous il la
majorité malheureusement ne mentez pas
ont répondu que c'était un kilo de plume
parce que on a notre faille qui
fonctionne à savoir on se représente la
plume comme étant quelque chose de léger
donc c'est nécessairement plus léger que
le plomb mais si c'est le même poids et
1 kg seulement 1 qu'il s'incline
question numéro deux au chant avec ce
total j'ai l'impression de repasser un
examen
bah c'est un peu vrai y en aura l'on
mette à chaîne youtube en jeu en fait ça
j'ai un traitement donné des codes et en
fait si tu as faux à ces cinq questions
je change le coche je te donne la chaîne
et je gagne quoi je gagne la tienne ce
que tu viens je crois des vidéos de
mentalisme également oui c'est pas mal
bon bien des analyses
question numéro deux dans une année il
ya combien de mois qui comporte 28 jours
tic tac tic tac
stop votre réponse dans les commentaires
maintenant la réponse de baja maraka et
ils comportent tous 28 jours oui oui
hélas y en a qui sont encore en train de
pas comprendre et il ya ben non il y
avait moins de 31 mai mois de 30 et le
moins de votes pourquoi ils comportent
tous 28 jours parce que si un jour à un
mois apprend qu'un jour c'est qu'il en a
28 exactement qui peut le plus peut le
plus peut le moins et également aussi du
coup donc oui c'est ça alors pourquoi
vous avez eu tendance à dire qu'il y
avait un seul mois parce que vous avez
focaliser sur une donnée précis c'est de
la manipulation par la donnée précise
on se dit j'ai une information et un
savoir en moi ça y fait référence
donc je n'écoute pas bien la question
c'est comme quand dans les commentaire
d'une vidéo vous dites oui mais ça j'ai
pas compris alors qu'il avait la réponse
dans la vidéo en fait c'est une question
focus sur l'ensemble des informations
mais là on a un beau spécimen de cerveau
tu vois là je suis dans le top ten kate
mondial ou pas je fasse un transfert
trop bien pour la frontière de mort pour
la prochaine question
toi tu vas l'avoir sur le panneau vous
vous l'aurez à l'écran tu parle anglais
lille b ok elle et ouais parce qu en
fait y'a pas à traduire mais je vais te
faire voir une phrase en anglais tu dois
compter le nombre de f qu'il ya dans
cette phrase s'il te plaît ok attention
c'est parti
c'est ici de 3,4 c'est bon combien de
4,4 votre réponse dans les commentaires
s'il vous plaît six exactement il y en
avait six siens et pas quatre temps à
oublier deux nécessairement ceux qui
l'ont pas oublié c'est soit que ils ont
vraiment des chiffres et ils ont pris le
temps ou alors qu'il parle pas du tout
anglais et du coup ils ont vu les mots
comme des mots nouveaux mets toi qui
parle anglais
tu n'as pas compter le f2 off et le f2
aof
tu as comptait se f oui ce f qui
augmentent également se f
et peut-être un des 3 way mais pas les 3
c'est pas possible j'ai pas j'ai pas eu
ces deux offres parce qu'en fait je me
suis focus sur la lys à chaque ligne y
assurait sur cette ligne c'est se f
il n'y a pas des flat et sur celle du
cfg ça c'est normal on se fait chier
mais c'est complètement comme qui
parlent anglais ça pour toi c'est pas
des vrais mots et ton cerveau il les lit
même pas en fait ces mots de liaison
quand tu lis quelque chose donc là quand
à chercher les lettres tu cherches
vraiment des vraies lettres de vrais
mots et que ton cerveau à identifier
c'est pour ça que tu t'es fait avoir
gagné même qu'ils voient que 3 f où
c'est sochaux un gros stupide qui a pas
bien content et je sais par contre que
les avaient tous trouvé c'est gênant ok
attention question de rapidité et vous
allez faire en même temps que benjamin
combien il ya deux doigts dans une main
5dans demain 10 dans dix vingt cent
cinquante
voici comment tu te fait manipuler
encore une fois par des biais cognitifs
parce que tu as fait 10 x 10 oui mais
j'ai dit dans dix mains pas dans vingt
dans une main 5 dans demain 10 donc dans
dix mains 10 10 10 10 et 10,50 main ça
va à une vitesse affolante n'est ce pas
sachant que géant je n'ai agi en général
5 de moyenne en mathématiques sur toute
ma scolarité et là j'étais content
d'avoir calculé le 10 sur 10 très très
rapidement tu vois ce que moi je
trouvais que c'était plus un problème
anatomique sentiments comme ça 8
attention jeu mentalisme vous étiez
menuisier ne marque pas beaucoup mais ça
c'est ça c'est terrible parce que ça
vous montre aussi à quel point c'est
facile de manipuler l'esprit de
quelqu'un sous pression en fait imaginez
vous êtes dans une situation de stress
mais quelqu'un qui vous demande quelque
chose il peut vous faire aboutir à une
réponse ou un résultat assez rapidement
cinquième question cinquième question ok
ok écoute moi bien écoutez moi bien je
te coûte comment peux-tu de tenir debout
derrière ton père alors qu'il est
derrière toi je suis debout je suis
derrière mon père alors qu'il est lui
même derrière soi
comment c'est possible j'aurai deux
paires mais je peux pas
4 alors je n'ai à moins que mon père a
le don d'ubiquité
lallaing là tu me pose une colle ok je
suis je suis derrière lui il est
derrière moi c'est très compliqué admet
tout à fait mon père ouais donc est
derrière moi je suis derrière toi mais
tu es aussi derrière moi mais je suis
aussi là comment c'est possible je lis
des commentaires là j'entends que ça
tape un petit peu non c'est pas ça
merci oui c'est ça évidemment là c'est
le problème de la précision en précisant
des choses dans un ordre précis tu vois
quelque chose d'impossible maintenant
excusez moi je suis derrière toi et
pourtant tu es derrière moi benjamin
d'erika à huy ohlala tu vois je me suis
fait avoir et au tout départ j'ai dit
quand tu peux être derrière ton père
donc ta instantanément une image de
hockey de ton père et moi derrière lui
alors que lui même est derrière toi et
là tu veut replacer la même image parce
que la première image pour toi est la
bonne en fait c'est le prêt ni c'est bon
tu vas chercher à inverser ça en fait
mais en fait c'est à cause de tout ça
qu'on ne peut pas faire une confiance
absolue dans notre cerveau en fait on
est habitué à lui faire confiance
on habitue à se dire toutes manières il
c est la première réponse qui nous
envoie est la bonne en fait c'est un
gros mytho
on est géré par un gros mytho - on n'a
pas tellement le choix en fait du coup
bon pour conclure en fait le cerveau il
va à l'essentiel le plus rapidement
possible c'est son job c'est la survie
c'est la compréhension immédiate à
sprinter c'est à sprinter et après
surtout par contre il a un peu dgo du
coup ils bloquent sur sa réponse il a du
mal à en sortir parce qu'ici c'est ça
c'est ça que je dis c'est qu'il a
vraiment cette ville enfin le mien donc
en fait ils ont mis plus que vous
perdiez ou quoi il y perd orgueilleux et
c'est d'ailleurs grâce à ça que les
tours de magie existe parce qu'en fait
on exploite ses failles cognitive en
exploite les défauts du cerveau à ce
moment là ok mais les magiciens
pop est fier de vous benjamin pour
terminer nous allons faire une
expérience de psychologie cognitive pour
voir à quel point on peut manipuler le
cerveau mais aussi la mémoire et donc de
pouvoir de décision parce que c'est pas
si simple ils décident à notre place
mais après il n'aime pas revenir en
arrière
donc là je décide quoi d'avoir une fin
de texte
donc je reviens pas en arrière exact
donc je ne sais pas quoi faire avec mon
cerveau mais je sais plus la griffe
connue
[Musique]
pourquoi vous deux
un paquet
là on a une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle je vais vous briefé sur la
bonne et la mauvaise nouvelle dans
quelques secondes
donc on a plus que du retard on a
beaucoup de retard mais c'est pas si
grave que ça en fait pour ceux qui ont
temps d'attendre
il va y avoir beaucoup d'attentes pour
la deuxième expérience mais en
contrepartie on prendra le contente de
faire les photos à la faim etc et on est
allé acheter des livres à moi c'est très
con d'acheter mes propres livres pour
vous les offrir ce qu'ils attendent
ok mais attends attends attends a prédit
pas applaudi pas on serait sur une fan
tournage vers 18 heures 18h 18h30
et pendant ce temps là malheureusement
il y aura juste à attendre pendant qu'on
tourne le reste voilà ces histoires des
très honnête et pour tous les autres
on vous fait partir à 16 heures grand
max comme prévu ok et et on prendra le
temps de faire les photos etc
à la fin est pour quand on a pas de
livre vaut mais tout se passe comme ça
doit se passer
voilà je vais vous donner je vais je
viens vous voir rapidement un par un je
vous demande si vous partez dans
longtemps ou pas longtemps et comme ça
je vous donne un petit truc de couleurs
comme ça on vous repère à chaque fois on
met en permanence à marcher
[Musique]
face à ces mêmes vexant parce qu'on
n'est pas loin ça te dire je vois pas de
ton bouquin oui ça m'est personnelle
ils ont rennais jusqu'à maintenant
surtout pas le bouc en fait je me suis
avancé sur le bouquin mais je ne sais
pas encore si on va désormais je vérifie
quelque chose ok petit changement de
programme
y'a pas de chiffres y'a pas de visible
du coup s'il y en a qui veulent changer
d'avis vous pouvez changer d'avis encore
mais vraiment parce qu'on a beaucoup en
plus de long donc si on a qui veulent
revenir sur du ballon on aura juste en
récompense des photos du coup on va
commencer par quoi je vais essayer que
de pain on perd trop de temps
alors merci beaucoup d'être ici d'être
venus si nombreux et si nombreux et et
je voulais déjà vous dire avant de
commencer quoi que ce soit que vous
venez donc de participer à une
expérience de psychologie cognitive à
l'instant qui s'appelle la technique de
l'amorçage pour
épouse tout à fait alors pourquoi on
vient de faire ça parce que c'est une
expérience assez passionnante qui montre
que lorsqu'une le cerveau a pris une
décision pour quelques raisons que ce
soit si la personne qui donnait les
informations au départ avant d'enlever
une quantité de bénéfices potentiels
n'avaient pas l'air d'être manipulatrice
alors le cerveau voulait rester quoi
qu'il arrive sur cette décision première
parce qu'il se sent beaucoup plus libre
ils recherchent la liberté en permanence
c'est à dire que au fur et à mesure
j'aurais pu la continuer à enlever des
bénéfices du cil a par contre comme
benjamin il devra partir et qu'on doit
rendre la salle on n'aura même pas le
temps de faire des photos ou des vidéos
et puis en fait ce sera pas 18 heures ce
sera 19h 19h30
quoi qu'il arrive l'amorçage aurait
fonctionné et ce pour la grande majorité
qui avait choisi l'expérience longue
serait resté toujours dans l'expérience
longue alors que plus ça va plus c'est
est relou et moi il y avait de bénéfices
pour vous avec juste vous allez attendre
entre des fauteuils benjamin c'est relou
oui ça j'ai les chiffres de l'expérience
d'origine c'est assez marrant à faire
parce que il avait fait dans les
expériences d'origine de cette
expérience de psychologie cognitive
plusieurs groupes des groupes qui
n'avait aucun bénéfice dès le départ et
des groupes qui avaient des bénéfices
vous avez fait ça la première fois avec
des étudiants qui devait quoi qu'il
arrive faire des heures d'expérience
pour valider leur diplôme ok on leur
avait dit il ya deux tâches qui à faire
une très compliqué enfin un peu relou à
faire mais ça vous donnera le double 2
heures que vous allez passer dessus et
une plus simple mais qui donnera le
nombre d'heures en réel une fois que les
gens avaient choisi
c'est là où ils auront retiré le
bénéfice du double oeuvre en fait non ce
sera juste le temps normal et alors
les chiffres sont les suivants ça donne
un effet jane mentalement dans
l'expérience initiale 80% des
participants avaient choisi la tâche la
plus compliquée ce qui est logique la
grande majorité comme la le ticket jaune
parce que l'amorçage vient déjà au
moment où vous vous déplacez jusqu'ici
vous êtes déjà dans une acceptation et
61% et est resté sur cette tâche une
fois le cadeau annulé avec 20% qu'elle
ait baissé sauf que dans le groupe test
il restait plus que 30 % des personnes
de départ donc voyez la différence entre
61 et 31 à l'énorme et donc je voulais
essayer juste de reproduire un peu
bêtement cette expérience là donc merci
d'avoir participé à ça et d'avoir montré
ce qu'était
fait de gel mentalement parlant qu'un
seul merci à benjamin verrecchia merci à
toutes les personnes qui sont venues
dans la vidéo merci à l'équipe technique
persie à fanny à la production à loïc à
la réalisation et surtout un grand merci
à one plus de m'avoir suivi encore une
fois je vais profiter de cette vidéo
pour le dire quand même mais cette année
ils m'ont suivi sur quatre gros projets
le concours de meutes calcul mental le
cluedo géant la vidéo je me suis fait
passer pour un voyant avec des trucs de
mentalist est aussi ce nouveau format
donc en plus d'avoir des téléphones
vraiment très stylé et très bad ass
ils ont l'audace de me suivre à
l'aveuglé sur tous mes projets merci à
vous trouverez un lien dans la
description vers l'édition spéciale du
mclaren si le nouveau format vous a plus
pensé à partager cette vidéo un petit
peu partout sur vos réseaux sociaux sur
install sur twitter etc
pensez à licques et c'est très important
à vous abonner à la chaîne pour voir les
nouvelles sorties
et s'il ya un point que vous aimeriez
voir dans les prochains épisodes pensé à
me le dire dans les commentaires
je voulais vraiment alors sommes nous
maîtres de notre cerveau ou est ce
l'inversé suffit-il d'être conscient
pour pouvoir lutter contre nos biennaux
fine aux raccourcis vous aurez bientôt
la réponse est bien plus dans les
prochains épisodes de matière grise
à très bientôt ciao